and the tigers for the first time will
see chris bubich who is making his
tent start and hud look at that he's got
his era under four
the one-owned swing the line drive base
hit into right field coming in
and almost playing himself into a bad
spot with merrifield picked the
in-between hop
before that ball got by him another rope
off the bat of miguel cabrera
another switch hitter and a ground ball
to third nice big hop franco he's going
to go the short way to second
one hit one left and tonight they'll get
michael fulmer
who's been a starter all year he's made
nine starts but he's only thrown 25
innings
and whitt drops one out into right field
that's gonna
fall in front of cameron and the royals
begin the bottom of the first with a man
on salvy had a two home run game last
night
he tied his career high with five rbis
and he has been absolutely amazing since
coming back from the injured list
and that is blasted into left field and
salvador perez
has a first inning three run home run
and even haye can't believe it
salvador perez continuing to stay hot at
fulmer he hasn't had a chance to even
work up a sweat
and here's the man of the day alex
gordon who announced it
his playing career will come to an end
after the game on sunday
bunt down the third base line michael
former will bare-handed and fire to
first whoa
he almost threw that into the runner
gordon trying to bunt his way out
tigers have two on with two out romina's
second paradis
is the runner at first and the two-two
pitch
on the way and he swings and misses and
that's the inning so perez got him
back on track lead off pan is on for the
tigers
willie castro batting boobage sets holds
it at the belt the pitch
swinging a high fly ball left field way
back and left and gone
wow willie castro put a charge into one
carried the bullpen
in left by a long shot number six is a
two run home run
for the now trail three two there's a
fastball
swung on and missed a strikeout of
candelario so
two outs now here's the pitch try to
check his swing but he went that's a
strikeout would have been ball
four but he checked his swing went too
far and strikes out so the royals have
their lead off man
on for the second time tonight and now
he lines one into center field that'll
get mondasee to third salvi will hold
with a single and he just keeps on
hitting
unbelievable first and third and nobody
out
franco hits it to right plenty deep to
get monday home
cameron makes a play look at salvi
and salvi moves up 90 feet how about
that
what an excellent read 4-2 royals here's
tyler
alexander with runners at first and
third and one out
2-1 swinging a line drive caught by
tyler alexander throws to first and they
double
off dozer at first how about that
great glove work by tyler alexander on a
bullet that was heading into center
field
inning ending line out unassisted one
over to three defend four two royals are
in the fifth man on nobody out the 3-2
pitch swinging the fly ball
center field deep going back cordero to
the fence looking up and it's gone
miguel cabrera is hot 10th home run of
the year is a two run shot to tie the
game at four here in the fifth
so one out the batter is monday
back to the middle and mondassey is
three for three so he's on base
again in front of salvador perez who got
him home with a three run home run
in the first inning monday edges off
alexander checks him
there goes modesty they've got him
picked off throw down to second base and
he is an easy out at second base
mondeceae took off alexander just
flipped over to dixon down to
good room 3-2 swinging the ground ball
to third base big hop for paredes a step
to the glove side easy flip over to
dixon at first
perez battles with alexander alexander
wins the battle at the end
and there are two on for willy castro
and barlow strikes him out
so a big strikeout of willy castro who
was on fire
coming into this ball game meantime han
continues his battle
with miguel cabrera here is the 2-2
pitch
swing grounder up the middle fielded by
lopez his toss to first base right on
the money and
the royals get out of a jam in inning
number six
bottom six franco the batter alexander's
still out there he's gone two and a
third
and there's a line drive into deep left
center field
and it is gone that looked like it hit
the base of the wall but
it cleared it and the royals are back in
front and here comes jorge soler
he fought it off and still hits it deep
into right center field and cameron will
not get it solaire has an rbi double and
jorge soler really showed off his power
there
and the royals have two in the sixth
inning joe jimenez
will come in with the bases loaded how
about a line drive
off of castro's glove that will score
two and alberto monteci drives in two
and the royals have four in the sixth
inning two on two
out castro's two for four tonight a 1-1
on the ground and under the glove of
lopez
romine will score reyes all the way to
third
and the tigers get one back here in the
eighth
and ripped to left center field another
run is home miguel cabrera
is seeing it again here tonight another
rbi for the tigers number three hitter
and suddenly it's a two-run ball game
fastball ground ball base hit into right
pass to diving nikki lopez
into score comes castro over to third
goes derek hill and the potential tying
runs now at third
tigers trailing eight to seven another
big two out rbi hit
and now there are two down in the ninth
inning and a ground ball to third
franco is over to first in time and jake
newberry
picks up his first major league save and
the royals take
game one from detroit royals have won 10
of their last 15.